god of the green lord of the forest I
offer you my sacrifice I ask you for
your blessing you are the man in the
trees the green man of the forest who
brings life to the dawn in spring you
are the deer in rut mighty horned one
who roams the autumn forest the hunter
circling around the oak the antlers of
the wild stag and the lifeblood that
spills upon the earth each season god of
the green lord of the forest I offer you
my sacrifice I ask only for your
blessing
the name caninus was one given to an
extremely powerful and ancient deity
that was widely worshipped throughout
the world and still lives even to this
day canoe nose can be translated to mean
horned one in Celtic and the Horned God
was just one of the many names that the
deity went by his origins can be traced
back to nearly every culture throughout
time but the name and appearance changes
canoe nose has his noni Celtic mythology
is perhaps the one we're most familiar
with he often appears as human or at
least human-like with the antlers of a
stag sometimes even with horns that we
dissociate of ass a tear or a form
resembling the Greek god of the wild pan
and much like the Greek god con unas was
seen to be a call of the wild nature and
fertility amongst many other things
being the deity so heavily associated of
nature he was often accompanied by a
group of animals that were thought to be
symbolic of the God the stag the bull
and the RAM he was also often seen
holding a horned or spotted snake
despite appearing as somewhat human many
believed that he wore a human face and
did not take a particular interest in
the concerns of humans he was a
protector of animals often being called
the Lord of animals and it's very likely
that few hunted in his woods without a
piece in the God first there are those
who saw his connection with animals has
also been connected to our own deeply
buried instinctual and animalistic
natures the earliest known depiction of
con unas were found in northern Italy
within the region of valcamonica which
was under Celtic occupation from around
400 BC his worship continued to grow in
the region of gold
which covered a host of countries in
Western Europe and the images of the
Holland God can even be found in the
French capital of Paris while digging
under the Cathedral of not Road on an
ancient pillar was found it was named
the pillar of the boatmen and it
contains 16 carved images from the
greco-roman Pantheon as well as some
Celtic inscriptions there is a coven of
a man with horns which has led many to
believe that it was indeed the home God
Canoe knows there are those who would
argue that the image could have also
been a depiction of the Greek god Pan
it's fairly difficult to read because of
the tablets age and the erosion and
damage caused over time but inscribed
above the image in Latin is the word air
Nuno which we can assume refers to the
Celtic interpretation of the Horned God
it's impossible for us to identify every
home God as con unas but the image on a
pillow shows a talk a piece of jewelry
that was common amongst the Celtic
people it was often used to show a
person of high status and in some other
cultures talks are thought to have
mystical powers being able to ward off
curses and provide the wearer of
protection during battle with con unas
being a god that was thought to protect
all animals he can be found wearing a
talk around his neck or hanging from his
antlers sometimes even just holding the
piece of jewelry in one hand with a
snake in the other one of the most
noticeable depictions of the Horned God
can be found on a dundas truck cauldron
where we see him holding a talk in a
serpent surrounded by numerous creatures
a dog a raven and a stag creatures that
we often see appear in tales of
mythology and folklore caninus was a God
worshiped in both pagan and Wiccan
practices the cycle of the seasons in
some working practices followed the
relationship between the home God and
the goddess with con unas representing
male energy v4 symbolized the death of
the Horned God as the land and
vegetation became dormant during the
autumn and winter in the spring however
the horn girdles were erected where he
would impregnate the fertile goddess of
the land this interpretation of the
Horned God and his relationship or
marriage with the mother goddess is a
relatively recent pagan and Wiccan
concept and was likely not one
celebrated by the Celtic people the
ancient Celtic people would have seen
and worshiped canoe not in a different
manner
they would often attempt a commune of
the God seeking to receive some of his
power dressing themselves in animal
skins and adorned in skulls to honor
full and wildlife there are theories
that the Celtic interpretation of the
Horned God could have evolved into what
the pagans believed to be the green man
a spirit associated of nature and man's
reliance on a cycle of growth that comes
with spring the green man sometimes
appears as an ordinary man covered in
leaves but sometimes he takes the form
of a walking tree similar to the race
events that we see in Tolkien's
middle-earth canoe notes at times as a
very misunderstood God for several
reasons naturally because of his homes
and the occasional depiction of a large
erect phallus images of con unas can be
misinterpreted as a symbol of Satan with
the Christian Church not taking kindly
to the worship of other deities they
quickly labeled the pagan following of
caninus as devil worship and they did
their best to discredit all aspects of
the home God's character constantly
comparing him to Satan as an attempt to
make it almost impossible to distinguish
between the two the depictions of Satan
at a time included horns that resembled
the Celtic deities we can assume that
this was done deliberately and it
certainly created confusion amongst
those who had never heard of the Celtic
interpretation of the Horned God there
are some accounts that associate con
unas with the underworld being somewhat
of a guide to the dead he was able to
move amazing stealth and grace being
able to walk through thickets and woods
without being seen or heard it's likely
the way that he moved was considered
otherworldly and thus he was thought
capable of walking in between the veil
that separated the realm of the living
from the realm of the dead he was known
to help guide the dead from their
previous life to their new one where he
encouraged them to continue the pursuit
of wisdom and happiness kanoon has been
seen as a prosperous God ties in of his
association with the Yule season the
13th of December until the 25th what
many of us will consider Christmas Day
during this period he was referred to as
the gift in stag a mystical creature
whose antlers were thought to symbolise
the strange powers of the winter
solstice season it was thought that
sometimes he would appear on the 26th of
December where he would encourage those
who receive gifts to give them away to
those less fortunate than themselves
there isn't much if any Celtic
literature surrounding Canoe knows and
this does lead to a lot of confusion
around the God what we do know for sure
is that he was a God who went by many
different names in many different
cultures
over the years he's been associated of a
host of different things he was the god
of the wild fertility wealth life and
death the hunt and of course animals
whether you believe con unas was one of
the many interpretations of the Horned
God or the original his influence in
aspects can be seen in many different
cultures from her nay the english god of
the wild hunt japan the great god of the
wild in greek mythology
Pacha party the lord of animals in hindu
mythology and even Blair's
the god of the forest in the slepak
pantheon sadly caninus is a god that we
don't know much about and the majority
of that falls on to the Christian Church
attempting to erase him from existence
as someone who is quite fond of the
Greek god Pan con unas is also a deity
that are naturally drawn to I don't
consider myself particularly well-versed
in Celtic mythology or pagan and wickham
practices so if there's anything I've
missed or you'd like to share your
thoughts with me I look forward to
hearing from you in the comments below
as always I've been your host with ology
and fiction explained